so this is very interesting we have
resolution
in some sense to one of the many
election lie
related lawsuits that are taking place
it's important to follow these stories
to their conclusions newsmax is one of
the right-wing media networks
that was spreading known demonstrable
debunkable lies about the 2020 election
in the months after the november
election
one of the targets of these lies was
dominion
voting systems which attracted the ire
of fox news newsmax
rudy giuliani sydney powell the mypillow
guy
many people going bonkers about dominion
voting system's supposed role in helping
to steal the election for donald trump
from donald trump for joe biden newsmax
specifically made such claims as
eric coomer an executive at dominion was
supposedly part of an
antifa conference call to rig
the election there were also other
claims about exactly how
dominion voting systems stole votes from
trump and gave them to biden
there's no evidence for any of this
stuff there never was so dominion voting
systems decided
to sort of try to throw the book at
these people
sued newsmax among others and the
newsmax lawsuit has now been settled
this is the first such settlement we
don't know the financial terms of the
settlement but presumably there is a
financial payoff here by newsmax
and of course we are led to believe
that uh this is only the first of many
but this is just the best tale between
the legs outcome
newsmax has published an apology now the
apology is sort of
bs but it's still interesting to look at
first of all they published it with the
completely anodyne title statement about
dr eric
coomer director of product strategy and
security at dominion voting systems okay
so let's look at this this is the the
retraction and apology
newsmax says since election day various
guest attorneys and hosts on use max
have offered opinions and claims about
dr eric coomer
newsmax would like to clarify its
coverage of dr coomer
and note that while newsmax initially
covered claims by president trump's
lawyers
supporters and others that dr coomer
played a role in manipulating
manipulating dominion voting machines
dominion voting software
and the final vote counts in the 2020
election newsmax subsequently found no
evidence that such allegations were true
so already they're framing it as
we were bystanders here we we did
nothing
there were people who came on and made
claims when we
looked into the truth of the claims we
found no evidence for them
now this is a very uh
sort of cynical view on the role of
newsmax
they knew from day one that there was no
evidence but they continued to allow the
claims to be made
so you know even the framing of the
apologies is pretty much bs
newsmax going on to say many of the
states whose results were contested by
the trump campaign
have conducted recounts and audits and
each state certified the results as
legal
and final there are several facts our
viewers should be aware of this is great
news max has found no evidence that dr
coomer interfered with dominion voting
machines or voting software in any way
nor that dr coomer ever claimed to have
done so nor has newsmax found any
evidence that dr coomer ever
participated in any conversation with
members of antifa
nor that he was directly involved with
any partisan political organization
on behalf of newsmax we would like to
apologize for any harm or reporting of
the allegations against coomer
may have caused to dr kumar and his
family for more go to our website and
read facts about dominion
now i love that they did this
but this is one of the most bs apologies
and retractions i've seen because
i mean listen first of all in general
with these apologies and retractions
they did months of the coverage and now
almost no one is going to hear
or value this apology which is
so narrow in scope understand that
they're not even retracting
general claims made about dominion all
they are saying is
the specific claims guests made
about dr coomer's role
are without evidence a lot of the claims
were more broad
about dominion voting systems as an as
an entity
as an organization they're not even
retracting or apologizing
about that never mind all of this other
stuff claims from sydney powell and mike
pillow about
venezuela hugo chavez whatever okay so
listen
uh presumably newsmax decided to settle
to avoid going forward because it would
cost them a lot more money
there's a risk for dominion also if the
lawsuit were to move forward and go to
court
maybe dominion doesn't win the
defamation suit
who knows both parties decided it was in
their interest to settle
but i received some emails from people
saying you know the apology
is so narrow and such bs that no one
will see
it might be more impactful if one of
these lawsuits
really led to the complete and total
demise of an organization like newsmax
i can see both sides because there are
risks to going to trial
i'm sure both sides accounted for those
risks in making their decision to settle
now in terms of what newsmax really
believes
as an entity it is obvious newsmax
never believe this stuff ever ever ever
they are
there there are people taking the
position that newsmax is saying this now
only because they have to but they still
believe the election was stolen no no no
no
maybe there are some hosts individually
that believe the election was stolen
i think the reality is newsmax as an
entity never believed this
they were going with it and allowing
guests to push it
for clicks that's all it was i don't
think there was any point at which
newsmax had an editorial position that
this election was stolen by joe biden
this is now one settlement we will see
what more comes of it there are many
more of these in play